on sunday uh also in dc another massive
rally this time marching against vaccine
mandates and um other forms of
covet-related tyranny
and here we have some footage of the
crowd here's what the crowd looked like
so we're here to rise above that
i think they
also you pan you see it
this looks like even bigger than the
march of light this has got to be one of
the biggest
that's remarkable
certainly one of the biggest uh
political demonstrations that we've seen
in dc in in several years at the very
least
uh but the left showed up as well and um
a rather pathetic turnout even more
pathetic than the than the counter
protesters of the march for life
so let's just watch here's here's here's
a there's a random smattering of some
pro-fouchy protesters and let's hear
let's hear what what point they have to
make or what their position is let's
listen
i love function
i love vouchers what they that's what
they have to say
and these remember these are these are
people on the left they would pretend to
be um
okay
they would pretend to be you know
they're part of the resistance they
still consider themselves the resistance
they're
uh you know revolutionaries they're down
with the the system and all that kind of
stuff they still affect that kind of
posture
but
they're they're chanting these are
counter protesters showing up to chant
about how much they love a government
bureaucrat
how much they love the highest paid
federal employee in american history
this is what they've shown up to do
and and yet they pretend to be uh
critics of of the system well uh one
thing i can tell you as a four-star chef
myself um amateur chef but i consider
myself a four-star chef your kitchen is
not complete without
great kitchen knives and that's why you
need cami coda kamikota taps into more
than 800 years of traditional techniques
from honshu japan kamikota also uses
steel sourced from mills in japan and
each blade is crafted using techniques
that have been honed and perfected by
generations of knife smiths each knife
comes in a beautiful heavy duty ash wood
box and makes sure that the knife is
stored safely as well each kamikota
knife goes through a rigorous 19-step
process that takes several years from
start to finish to complete our expert
blade smiths forge and shape raw steel
into hardy blades uh polishing and
sharpening them to an excruciatingly
fine edge each knife is individually
inspected kamikoto is so confident that
their knives will work for you that each
knife comes with a lifetime guarantee
because of their single bevel edge
candecoto knives can achieve an
unbelievably sharp edge you just can't
get with other knives they can cut
through your rib eye like butter that is
guaranteed
kamikoto is currently having a massive
extended new year sale and on top of
that sale you can get an additional 50
50 off any purchase you make with
discount code mat wall so click the link
below or go to camacota.com matt walsh
and use promo code matt walsh to save an
extra 50 today and it gets worse than
that because some of these kind of
protesters were even more aggressive and
here's one woman who um
showed up in a in her van
and uh she she had a more she had a
little bit more to say and let's let's
hear her out
so that these
white supremacists can party and have a
good time celebrating their loser
president
trump god
stop invading our territory
go to the home take your loser president
and shove him up here
white supremacist of course and she's
got i don't know what's going on with
her van she has uh she's like a she's
she's literally in a serial killer van
with hand prints the handprints of all
of her victims are on the uh you can see
the you can see the handprints on the
windows
of people calling to get out
and uh on her way to murder her next
round of victims she she decided to stop
and yell at all the um at all the
protesters there because of course
they're all they're all white
supremacists
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content